A
hundred years ago, Egyptologist James Henry
Breasted described Hatshepsut as “the first
great woman in history of whom we are informed.”
This is particularly ironic seeing as how
one or more pharaohs who came after her tried
to have her erased from history through damnatio
memoriae.
Maybe they hated her, maybe they resented
her success, or maybe they simply wanted a
return to tradition.
Thankfully, they did not succeed, which means
that today we can bring you the story of Hatshepsut,
the woman who became a pharaoh.
To Be a Female Pharaoh
Hatshepsut was born circa 1508 BC.
She was part of Egypt’s 18th Dynasty which
was founded by Ahmosis I and became notable
for several reasons.
For starters, it also included other well-known
historical figures such as Tutankhamun and
Nefertiti.
More importantly, though, it was the first
dynasty of the so-called New Kingdom, a period
in ancient Egyptian history which is considered
one of its “Golden Ages.”
Some even hail it as the most prosperous time
for the empire.
This is debatable - others could argue that
the Old Kingdom which was defined by the construction
of the pyramids represented the true halcyon
days of Egypt - but one thing that’s certain
is that, after the New Kingdom ended, the
empire experienced steady decline and would
never again reach the same heights.
This dynasty is also known as the Thutmosid
Dynasty because several of the first pharaohs
were named Tuthmosis, or Thutmose, however
you prefer.
Hatshepsut herself was the daughter of Tuthmosis
I, stepsister (and wife) of Tuthmosis II,
and stepmother of Tuthmosis III.
Speaking of names, we already gave a brief
rundown on the naming conventions for pharaohs
in our Tutankhamun video which you can check
out if you haven’t seen yet.
Basically, the full royal titulary included
five separate names.
Our pharaoh today typically went by Hatshepsut
which was part of her personal name, but she
was also often referred to by her throne name
of Maatkare.
Hatshepsut is sometimes identified as the
first female pharaoh and this is not really
true.
She is certainly the first on whom we have
good information and you can make a strong
case that she was the greatest female pharaoh,
but she was not the first.
Unfortunately, we cannot say with accuracy
who was the first because there is a lot of
uncertainty surrounding the rulers of the
earliest dynasties.
There were plenty of female regents who ruled
as guardians of child monarchs until they
came of age.
However, as early as the First Dynasty, it
is possible that queens such as Merneith or
Neithhotep may have ruled, at least for a
short while, as pharaohs in their own right.
The first one on whom we have pretty solid
evidence is Sobekneferu.
After her brother, Amenemhat IV, died without
a male heir, she took the throne and ruled
for almost four years.
Statues and inscriptions of Sobekneferu depict
her with the full royal regalia and titles
of a pharaoh.
Like her brother, she also did not have any
heirs so her death also brought the end of
the 12th Dynasty.
Her Rise to Power
Hatshepsut was the daughter of Pharaoh Tuthmosis
I and his Great Royal Wife, Ahmose.
It was common for pharaohs to have multiple
wives, but only one was the main wife who
had certain authority and performed functions
we would associate with a queen.
Normally, the heir of the pharaoh was also
the son of the Great Royal Wife, but this
was not always the case.
Indeed, that was not what we had here.
Tuthmosis II succeeded to the throne after
his father’s death circa 1493 BC, but he
was not the son of Ahmose, but rather a secondary
wife called Mutnofret.
The new pharaoh married his stepsister Hatshepsut
when she was about 12 years old.
They only had one child that we know of, a
daughter called Neferure.
The pharaoh’s other known child was his
heir, Tuthmosis III, whom he had with his
secondary wife Iset.
The reign of Tuthmosis II is one full of questions,
including how long it actually lasted.
The traditional length which comes from ancient
sources is 13 to 14 years, but some modern
Egyptologists argue that it may have been
a full decade shorter.
Assuming the older version, then the pharaoh
would have died in 1479 BC.
Technically, he was succeeded by his son,
Tuthmosis III, but the new king was only two
or three years old so his stepmother, the
Great Royal Wife Hatshepsut, ruled as his
regent.
So far, everything went according to protocol,
but Hatshepsut was expected to cede all authority
when Tuthmosis came of age.
She didn’t, though.
Instead, she took the power for herself and
became a fully fledged pharaoh.
Unfortunately, we don’t have the complete
details of her rise to the throne.
We don’t know if it was something gradual
as Hatshepsut kept awarding herself more and
more authority or if she took over in one
fell swoop.
We do know that in the early years of her
regency, she still used traditional titles
such as “King’s Chief Wife” or “God’s
Wife” and was portrayed sitting behind or
to the side of the young pharaoh.
However, around the seventh year of Tuthmosis’s
reign, she began being depicted as the King
of Egypt, with all the titles and regalia
that came with it.
What would have been nice to know is how the
people of Egypt reacted to Hatshepsut’s
power play.
She ruled as pharaoh for well over a decade
so, clearly, they weren’t that up in arms
about it, but that may also be due to the
fact that she took extra steps to gain their
approval.
For starters, Hatshepsut established her divine
legacy, which was easy to do since she was
the daughter of Tuthmosis I, and she also
claimed that it was always his will for her
to rule alongside her stepbrother.
Afterwards, she obtained the support of the
high officials.
How exactly she did this, we don’t know,
probably with bribes and promotions, but we
do know the name of one man who achieved great
status during her reign.
His name was Senenmut and he was, among others,
the Great Treasurer, the Chief Royal Architect,
and the Chief Steward of the King’s Daughter.
Because of his swift rise to power, there
has been speculation that he and Hatshepsut
might have been lovers, but there is no proof
of this.
His true legacy is the mortuary temple that
he designed and built for Hatshepsut which
remains, even today, among the most recognizable
examples of ancient Egyptian architecture.
Moreover, there was also the ceiling decoration
of his own tomb which contains a celestial
diagram and represents one of the most detailed
displays of Egyptian astronomy.
The last step in Hatshepsut’s process to
secure power was the most unusual as it had
not been employed by any of the other female
pharaohs - Hatshepsut portrayed herself as
a man.
There are statues and inscriptions of her
where she was clearly depicted with a male
body and described using male pronouns.
She even had the fake, pointy beard that we
see on a lot of pharaohs.
That being said, this practice wasn’t universal
and we also have statues where Hatshepsut
is shown as a woman, as well as inscriptions
where she used feminine titles such as the
“Female Horus” or “Daughter of Ra.”
Perhaps once she felt that her position was
secure, she abandoned the custom.
The Reign of the Pharaoh
Now we move on to Hatshepsut’s motivation
for her power grab.
Many historians believe she did it purely
to satisfy her ambition.
In fact, when Hatshepsut’s story was first
being unraveled about a century ago, she was
portrayed in a very negative light.
Scholars of that time accused her of acts
of deception and deviant behavior.
They called her the “vilest type of usurper”
and a “vain, ambitious, and unscrupulous
woman.”
They said that her husband, Tuthmosis II,
was a frail and weak ruler whom she easily
pushed around and manipulated while the scheming
Senenmut was her co-conspirator and lover.
Meanwhile, Tuthmosis III grew up loathing
his stepmother and took revenge on her after
she died by trying to erase her name from
history.
It’s a compelling story where Hatshepsut
portrays the villain, but one that has fallen
out of favor with today’s scholars who consider
it based more on the preconceptions of the
time rather than hard proof.
While it is possible, even likely, that it
was Hatshepsut’s desire for power which
determined her actions, to say that she was
a deviant, ruthless usurper is a tad too far.
After all, if she was really so cold-blooded,
she would have found a way to get rid of her
stepson since he was the biggest threat to
her power, especially after he came of age,
but she never did.
She didn’t threaten or persecute him.
Tuthmosis was allowed to do as he pleased.
He first trained as a soldier and then became
the commander of the Egyptian army.
In fact, some historians opine that Hatshepsut
did exactly the opposite, that she took power
during a political crisis to protect herself
and Tuthmosis from another pretender to the
throne from a different branch of the royal
family.
Once she did it, it was a lifetime gig so
she couldn’t surrender power even if she
wanted to.
Or maybe she was telling the truth all along
when she said that her father wanted her to
succeed as pharaoh.
It’s unlikely, but not impossible.
Motivations aside, let’s talk about Hatshepsut’s
actual reign.
Was it any good?
Well, in fact, it was, and historians describe
it as a period of prosperity for Egypt.
It was also relatively peaceful.
There is mention of some military expeditions,
but we don’t know any significant details.
Because they were so poorly documented, scholars
opine that Hatshepsut did it more out of a
sense of obligation, feeling that it was her
duty to continue the conquests of her father.
The true triumphs of Hatshepsut’s reign
as pharaoh came from trade and construction.
According to records, she re-established a
network with one of their former trade partners
during the Middle Kingdom, a mysterious land
known as Punt.
An ancient inscription says that the pharaoh’s
ships returned filled with ebony, ivory, myrrh,
cinnamon wood, and the “green gold of Emu”
aka electrum.
Nowadays, we’re not even sure where Punt
was exactly.
Best guesses suggest southeast of Egypt along
the Red Sea coast over parts of modern countries
such as Somalia, Eritrea, and Sudan.
Hatshepsut was also a prolific builder.
The age of the pyramids might have been over,
but she wanted to show that Egypt was still
capable of grand constructions.
She started off with monuments at the Temple
of Karnak.
There, she erected twin 100-ft tall obelisks
which, at the time, were the tallest in the
world.
She was clearly a fan of these giant stone
pillars as she ordered the construction of
several more throughout her reign.
The biggest of them all cracked while it was
being carved and it was simply abandoned in
its quarry in Aswan.
It has since become known as the Unfinished
Obelisk and not only is it still there today,
but it has provided us with unique insight
into how the ancient Egyptian stone workers
built these monuments.
Of course, Hatshepsut’s masterpiece was
her mortuary temple, the Djeser-Djeseru or
“Holy of Holies.”
It had three levels decorated with reliefs
and statues.
Each level had colonnades which told of Hatshepsut’s
triumphs.
The Birth Colonnade, for example, presented
her divine creation and how the god Amun was
her true father.
The Punt Colonnade, as you might expect, detailed
how she, once again, brought riches from the
Land of Punt back to Egypt.
There were several temples and chapels dedicated
to the gods.
There were also several tombs located in proximity,
such as that of Senenmut, the chief architect
of her mortuary temple.
For unknown reasons, he was never placed inside
his tomb and we do not know where he is buried.
Speaking of which...
Where Is Hatshepsut’s Mummy?
As with many pharaohs, the story of Hatshepsut
has continued into modern times thanks to
archaeologists finding her tomb.
However, her contemporary tale is a long and
complicated one that stands out from the rest
because it has been developing for over 200
years.
Hatshepsut died in 1458 BC and was buried
in a royal tomb dubbed KV20, originally alongside
her father, Thutmosis I.
The tomb itself is notable because Egyptologists
believe it may have been the first of its
kind built in the region known today as the
Valley of the Kings.
The first mention we have of the tomb in modern
times actually comes to us courtesy of Napoleon.
Maybe not him personally, but the scientific
expedition he sent there in 1799.
It was part of his campaign into Egypt and
Syria which mostly consisted of him fighting
the Ottoman and the English Empires.
On the military side, the campaign was a flop
- Napoleon failed to conquer Syria and, while
he did capture Egypt, he later had to surrender
it in order to withdraw.
On the scientific side, however, it turned
out to be one of the most significant expeditions
in history.
A large contingency of 167 engineers and scientists
from all areas of study traveled to Egypt.
They mapped the area and recovered thousands
of items.
Of particular importance was the discovery
of one artifact by a young engineer named
Pierre-François Bouchard - an artifact without
which we would have never been able to understand
the language, traditions, and history of the
Egyptians - the Rosetta Stone.
These discoveries triggered renewed interest
in ancient Egypt back in Europe and, more
or less, helped establish the field of Egyptology.
As far as KV20 was concerned, the French found
it and mapped it, but it was buried under
rubble so they did not explore it.
In 1817, pioneering Italian Egyptologist Giovanni
Battista Belzoni also made note of the tomb’s
location but, like before, he did not have
the time, resources, or disposition to excavate
it.
By the way, that Belzoni was quite a character
and lived a fascinating life, one you can
learn about in detail in the video we did
on him a while back.
Getting back to Hatshepsut, it wasn’t until
1825 that an attempt was made to excavate
her tomb by British scholar James Burton.
He only made it as far as the first chamber.
Afterwards came German Egyptologist Karl Richard
Lepsius in 1844 who mapped out parts of the
tomb but, again, failed to make any significant
progress.
It wasn’t until 1904 that someone finally
managed to clear out all the debris and completely
excavate KV20 and that someone was Howard
Carter, the same archaeologist who would discover
the tomb of Tutankhamun 18 years later.
Carter completely cleaned out the tomb of
all its contents, but afterwards came the
hard part of trying to make sense of what
he found.
There were quite a few artifacts which had
inscriptions mentioning Hatshepsut as the
“King of Upper and Lower Egypt,” cementing
the idea that she served as pharaoh in her
own right and not just as regent.
However, what puzzled Egyptologists was the
presence of two sarcophagi...but no mummies.
Both had been built for Hatshepsut, yet neither
one contained any remains.
The mystery of why there were two coffins
was solved relatively easily when archaeologists
translated the hieroglyphics.
Part of the inscription said “ ...long live
the Female Horus...
Hatchepsut-Khnemet-Amun!
May she live forever!
She made it as her monument to her father
whom she loved...Thutmosis the justified.”
Basically, the first sarcophagus had been
built for Hatshepsut, but then she refurbished
it for her father so that they would be buried
together.
However, Tuthmosis I was later removed from
the sarcophagus and placed inside another
tomb, KV38.
This was supposed to be a grander mausoleum
more befitting someone of his stature, but
this tomb was discovered and completely plundered
by looters.
That still left one big question: What happened
to Hatshepsut?
Her remains were probably removed alongside
those of her father, but where were they?
Over the decades, several potential candidates
were put forward.
Hatshepsut became similar to Nefertiti, another
famous Egyptian queen whose remains have yet
to be found.
Every time a new female mummy was discovered
that was about the right age, people speculated
that she might be the long-lost pharaoh.
One of those candidates was a nameless mummy
discovered in 1903, also by Howard Carter,
in Tomb KV60.
This was a modest tomb which belonged to Sitre
In, a woman who held the title of royal wet
nurse to Hatshepsut.
Her remains were also located inside the crypt
so this begged the question of who was the
second mummy?
Egyptologist Elizabeth Thomas was the first
to speculate in the 1960s that the unidentified
mummy might be Hatshepsut.
Back then, however, technology wasn’t ready
yet to support her hypothesis.
It wasn’t until last decade that we finally
got some evidence to back up the idea.
Besides the mummy, archaeologists had previously
recovered other items belonging to Hatshepsut
from her mortuary temple.
Among them was a wooden box with her name
on it which contained a preserved molar purported
to be that of the pharaoh.
In 2007, forensic orthodontists took the tooth
and compared it to several mummies believed
to be Hatshepsut to see if any of them matched.
Indeed, the one found in KV60 fit the bill
exactly, prompting many scholars to proclaim
that, at long last, Hatshepsut had been found.
To strengthen their argument, DNA tests also
showed that the mummy shared genetic similarities
to Ahmose-Nefertari, the first queen of the
18th Dynasty.
That’s not conclusive, but it did show that
they were related and, therefore, the KV60
mummy came from a royal bloodline.
This proof was enough for many Egyptologists,
although plenty of others remain skeptical
to this day.
Death & Disappearance
Let’s assume, like many others did, that
the mummy found in KV60 is, indeed, Hatshepsut.
In that case, we can also start talking about
her cause of death.
Ancient sources are quiet on the subject as
the pharaoh simply disappeared from the historical
record, although it is generally presumed
that she died in her 22nd regnal year.
If the mummy is Hatshepsut, then she wasn’t
exactly the peak of good health.
Shocking, I know.
The pharaoh was an overweight middle-aged
woman with arthritis, bad skin, bad teeth,
she may have suffered from diabetes and probably
died of skin cancer.
Worst of all, she may have given herself cancer
by using a carcinogenic skin treatment.
In the same place that archaeologists found
the wooden box with Hatshepsut’s tooth,
they also recovered a flask.
At first, they thought it originally contained
perfume, but later they concluded that it
was some sort of lotion used to treat a skin
condition like psoriasis or eczema.
It contained traces of harmless ingredients
such as oils and fatty acids, but also a tar
residue that could cause cancer.
It’s impossible to say how long the pharaoh
used the lotion for, but it is definitely
possible that she inadvertently poisoned herself
to alleviate the symptoms of her skin disease.
That could potentially solve the riddle of
Hatshepsut’s death, but there is still the
mystery of her disappearance.
By all accounts, Hatshepsut was condemned
to damnatio memoriae after death, the process
where her name and her actions were removed
from the historical record to try and make
it look like she never existed.
The question is “Why?”
In this regard, scholars only have ideas and
speculations.
Many have pointed the finger at the obvious
suspect, her stepson, Tuthmosis III, or possibly
his son and successor, Amenhotep II (or even
both of them).
The motives were varied.
We have no document or artifact to suggest
how Tuthmosis felt about his stepmother, but
he could have resented her for, basically,
usurping his power when she was just supposed
to rule as regent.
He also could have wanted to eliminate her
reign in order to create a more direct lineage
to his father and grandfather, Tuthmosis II
and Tuthmosis I.
If that’s the case, though, the damnatio
memoriae was more likely ordered by Amenhotep
than his father.
Tuthmosis III became a great pharaoh in his
own right and his claim to the throne was
unquestionable.
In fact, he was ancient Egypt’s most successful
military ruler and created the largest Egyptian
empire in history and he is also someone you
will probably see on this channel in the near
future.
Amenhotep II, on the other hand, was not his
father’s first choice as successor.
He was not his firstborn son, nor was he given
birth by Tuthmosis’s Great Royal Wife, Satiah.
However, the original heir, Prince Amenemhat,
and his mother both died, thus allowing Amenhotep
to take the throne.
The pharaoh could have felt that his royal
claim was not as strong as it could be, so
he sought out to create a direct lineage to
the first rulers of the 18th dynasty and eliminate
outliers, by which we mean Hatshepsut.
Or it could be that the motive was far less
personal and it simply represented a return
to tradition.
Hatshepsut’s reign, even though it was successful
and helped the empire prosper, went against
the norm.
Some argue that it was a problem exactly because
it was successful, as it showed Egyptians
that women could make good pharaohs, too,
and they couldn’t have that, could they?
Whatever the reason might have been and whoever
may have wanted Hatshepsut erased from the
history books, the important thing is that
they did not do a very good job.
Most of the small artifacts that had her image
or inscriptions with her name were left alone.
Even the bigger stuff like statues or stelae
were just smashed up and buried outside her
temple.
When archaeologists excavated the area in
the 19th and 20th centuries, they were able
to recover enough information to restore Hatshepsut’s
name and allow her to, once again, take her
rightful place as one of the greatest pharaohs
in history.